Hello.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to my humble tomato farm.
Everyone always asks me, why is the server called the tomato farm?
Why are there farmers?
Why are there tomato wardens?
Well you see children...
You see... I have a tomato.
Welcome to the farm children.
I had to... I was getting a bit too high outside.
I had to take off my skin suit real quick.
Ah yes.
Um... a little tomatoes.
It's still April first year.
Welcome to my farm everyone.
Welcome.
As you see here, my children.
I... I harvest my children here.
And then we eat them.
Nice Maro.
Ah yes.
Thank you.
Is it a new model?
Or was it inside me all along?
Was it inside me all along the chat?
Felicity thank you for the five gift subs.
Thank you for donating to the tomato farm.
Thank you.
The inside you.
I can't see you.
I can't reach your file.
Felicity.
Thank you.
Thank you for contributing to the farm.
The internet.
Ah thank you.
Thank you Victor.
For the tier one for nine months.
Oh that's nine tomatoes right there.
Nine tomato children right there for you.
I'm here for the point.
Doki is a V-tomato confirmed V-tuber.
I would like to say V-tomato.
Tomats.
V-tomats.
Oh shit.
Is there a country daily song though?
I don't know if there's a country daily.
Let me see.
Let me see if I can find country.
We might have to change up our daily song real quick.
I think we know what country song we should do for our daily song today.
Oh thank you so much everybody.
I just left .
Thank you.
Welcome to the Tomato farm.
West Virginia.
One kiss alright.
Alright Felicity.
Just for you.
Our kitty bewildering eyes.
Everyone close your eyes for the tomato kiss.
Take me home to the place I belong!
Oh shit, okay, wait, wait, wait, this is gonna hurt me too.
Alright.
Welcome to tomato town.
Oh shit, I gotta flip you off too?
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, this doesn't work very well, wait.
Wait, I can do this.
Guys, don't worry!
This will work, don't worry guys.
Here we go.
This is for Sid.
Don't worry!
There we go.
Take me home to the place I belong!
Don't...
It was not this kind of thing.
I'm disappointed now.
Everyone keeps asking me, why is our server called the tomato farm?
Now we know why.
Inside my skin suit was a tomato all along.
Inside all of us were tomats all along, chat!
Why could they never catch up to the tomato burglar?
They can't catch up to the...
I love it, bye.
Thank you everyone for coming to my VTuber TV Tomatoes and Feet.
West Virginia!
Country mama!
Ciao, thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you.
What's the backstory though?
It is...
Oh, you guys want to see me dance?
To the place I belong!
Yeah!
West Virginia!
Mountain mama!
Take me home!
Country mama!
Country rooome!
Oh...
Country rooome...
Where to take me home...
I like how I'm in the apex category, because this is supposed to be a quick, like, 5-10 minute joke.
But I'm still here!
I'm still here!
I'm never leaving!
Yeah, it's still... technically, it might be April 2nd to most people of the rest of the world, but it's still April 1st here on West Coast.
So we're living our tomato life.
We're still gonna live our tomato life.
Does this tomato work all day and night to earn the respect of their parents?
And at their college graduation, they take the phone and say, well, I guess I caught up.
Castle Life is leading me to my stream.
Over 4 hours here for it.
I wonder how much everyone's watching this joke.
Okay, alright.
I have a confession to make.
I've had this model on standby for 4 months.
I didn't know what to do with it.
And I was like, oh shit, wait, April 1st?
I had this model on standby for 4 months.
Because I was like, what am I gonna do with this?
I was like, oh shit!
I didn't know what to do with it.
I just wanted a tomato model.
But I know, I couldn't think of any reason to use it.
For 4 months.
It plays off the other joke in a multi-layered fashion exactly.
What do you mean joke?
This is my true self.
Right here.
What are you saying?
I've had this discussion at the tomato farm.
I've been a farm server for years.
We are out here harvesting my children.
For consumption.
And that is okay, farmers.
Remember, when you...
Remember, by subbing to me, you become a farmer.
You become a tomato farmer on our tomato farm.
Isn't that lovely?
Hi Ruby!
You don't even have a nose.
Who needs noses as a tomato?
What am I gonna smell?
Huh?
Sorry, I...
Who is this tomato?
We were all tomatoes all along.
It's honest work.
It ain't much.
But it's honest work chat.
What happened to Doki?
What's the meme?
This was me online.
This was inside my skin suit.
I just unzipped myself.
Please don't eat me.
So are the higher tier tomato farmers like managers over the lower ranks?
Of course.
Thank you.
Just wiped out tomato town.
Reject anime.
Return to tomato.
Exactly.
These are my children right here.
I don't know if you guys can see my children.
Right here.
Now I'm gonna eat my children.
Delicious.
It's called survival of the fittest.
They were strong enough.
Tomatoes are awesome people.
My children were not strong enough.
But don't worry.
We can make more.
We can harvest more of my children.
This is Doki Bird.
What do you mean?
This was me all along.
This was inside all of us all along.
We are all tomatoes in the inside.
How do you think tomatoes are grown?
Huh?
The Doki motto.
It was very very awesome.
You know tomatoes are from space?
Wait what?
I didn't even know that.
Doki woke up and chose violence.
Tomato cannot Doki.
Made it into pizza.
Save Doki.
Maybe you look great even without makeup.
Love the natural look.
Thank you.
This is me wiping down all the human makeup.
And the human suit.
I took it off and here I am.
I thought you were...
Alright guys.
Alright so let's actually get into the Apex.
You know I think we we had our fun.
Let me do a little tomato dance.
Real quick.
Happy April Fools.
I didn't...
I honestly came up with this like in 30 to 40 minutes.
Because I was like.
Should I do a shout out thing for April 1st?
I was like.
Oh shit yeah I have this tomato model.
On standby for 4 months now.
Like maybe this is a good time to use it.
Why do I have a tomato model?
Why do I not have a tomato model?
Excuse me?
I think everyone should have a tomato model.
Yeah why don't you have a tomato model?
Excuse me?
What?
We are called a tomato farm for a reason?
You think I was no...
You think I did it out of...
Do you think like there was no purpose to the tomato farm?
To my server?
Do you really think there was no purpose?
It still is here.
Alright guys.
I'm gonna go set up for the actual Apex stream.
I'll catch you guys later in like 3 minutes.
2 to 3 minutes.
And we're gonna pew pew.
We're gonna pew pew.
Let me put on my skin suit real quick chat.
I need a...
I need to put on my skin suit guys.
Real quick.
But yeah join the tomato farm.
Become tomato farmers.
Alright guys I'll be right back.
I'll be right back.
Hello.
I had to... It took me a while to zip back up the human suit.
But...
It took a while to put it back on.
But here we are.
Do not worry.
There's a tomato in all of us.
Also thank you so much for the follow.
Laz and Hinen.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
What happened to the real Doki?
What do you mean?
This is the real Doki.
What do you...
I feel like I just woke up from a dream I had at the tomato farm.
Man it was crazy.
Alright let me go.
Let me put my streaming playlist on real quick.
And pew pew.
Pew pew pew pew.
With our dad.
And Wapik.
Our personal singer.
I feel like I'm being... What do you mean?
Does this space look like a liar to you?
He asks a lot.
Alright let me join the voice chat real quick.
Hello?
Alright.
You guys ready to pew pew?
I want to get tomato Doki back.
Tomato Doki?
How about this?
If we win this game... If we win a game I'll swap to tomato farm.
Every game we win I'll play...
I'll be tomato Doki.
That's definitely the face of a god artist.
Wapik.
Anyone who is late to the stream will have a life changing experience.
Alright.
We need to win a lot.
Hahaha.
Tomato Doki.
I'll send him a tomato redeem after the stream too.
For the next year.
Hmm.
Unfortunate if I suddenly die.
We'll be very unfortunate guys.
Imagine the power boosted from the teasing tomato farm.
Tomato is coming back.
Bug.
Mabel's boss actually heard beer tomato head.
Confirmed.
Have you ever seen hair on tomatoes?
Gosh.
Hahaha.
Or maybe underneath this hat is a tomato stem.
We'll never know.
Hahaha.
What is this tomato Doki?
I don't understand.
You'll see one day.
Don't worry.
Hahaha.
Hmm.
We will never know.
Hahaha.
You'll know when you're older.
Alright.
So every win.
Every win will get you a game of tomato.
Of tomato me.
So.
It will be very unfortunate.
If I.
If I run at people with no armor.
Very unfortunate indeed.
Hahaha.
Maybe it's both.
Alright.
This is a.
We're gonna sweat so hard.
We're gonna make two sweating pools guys.
Hahaha.
Unless I'm lying.
There's gonna be a short stream today too.
Cause I'm sort of a bit tired.
But I have to do this.
Getting free new damage.
20 plus bomb to make a fourth game.
Where the fuck am I dropping?
I'm already messing up.
Do you sweat tomato juice?
Hmmm.
All this tomato lore.
That we will find out on April 16th.
15th?
I don't even know my own lore date.
Was it 15 or 16 that I have the lore stream?
I don't remember.
Hahaha.
In two weeks.
We'll find all this out in two weeks.
There's like a team like.
There?
Question mark?
52.
I don't even remember my own date.
Hahaha.
I just remember it's like in two weeks.
Alright.
They're here.
The car's on the roof.
Oh they sent the car.
Alright I am gonna lose.
You guys will be fine right?
Hahaha.
I am not concerned about dying here.
I can't believe we've done this.
What?
I heard it's a safety base day after my birthday.
Hahaha.
Wait where did they go?
Over that way.
Oh okay.
I am gonna take this car.
Oh you know I don't need that car.
Oh there's a guy over here.
Oh what the fuck?
Don't worry guys.
You can die if you want to.
It's okay.
What the fuck?
What is this?
Oh is this the April Fools event?
You guys will be fine right?
I am looting.
Oh okay.
Hahaha.
I am coming over.
Inside?
It's okay I am a smith.
I am taking the car.
Oh it is not okay anymore.
Oh my god.
They are both cracked.
Hahaha.
Oh he armor swapped.
Yeah he armor swapped off me.
It's okay.
That means I don't have to be tomato.
Hahaha.
I am sorry.
I have not played.
I think I played like...
3D... I should take the kill.
I think I haven't really played the past like 4 days.
I think I played like 40 minutes the past 4 days.
Um.
And I did not warm up before I set the tomats.
And before I set up the tomato vtuber.
Hahaha.
I did not warm up at all.
Hey terminal.
I am not sure what I am doing.
So this is all.
No tomato no win.
Hahaha.
Tomato is all the way.
Tomato vtuber heck yeah.
This will be a short stream too guys.
I just need to warn you in advance.
This will be a short stream.
Hahaha.
Lately to be honest to be fair for you guys.
Lately I have been feeling the burn out slowly creeping in on me.
Only because like.
Because of all this like partner.
Um.
Are you gonna throw the game away?
Or no what do you mean?
Also hi.
Hi Alice.
Why are we dropping boys?
Yeah I have been like.
Feeling very.
Like I have been feeling sort of the burn out coming in lately.
Because I have not really had a break in a while.
Ever since like trying to push for.
Uh.
Push for partner.
And it is like such a vicious cycle.
Because I have to reapply every two weeks.
And it is like I can't just.
I can't like take a break.
While I am in that like weird area.
Of reapplying every two weeks.
So it is like.
I am like in this weird purgatory place.
Alright.
Wait were we going inside?
I was not listening.
I am going inside.
Same.
Alright we are all going inside.
We are up next.
I think there is people on the map.
I am not sure.
It is okay I have.
Do not loot my stuff.
How did you loot it faster than me?
I was there first.
Stop looting my stuff.
Oh my god.
Wait how did you get my blue armor?
I am so confused.
Who are you?
Oh my god.
Poor guy.
What the fuck?
What?
I am so confused.
I killed two.
Where is the caustic?
Inside?
I heard someone inside.
Hey Logan.
I mean when you are about to win.
Let the ush kill.
So it will not become a debate.
There are people outside now.
I am not going outside first.
Going outside.
I love you too.
Yeah I am with you.
Oh you guys are going out.
I told you I did not want to loot everything.
Food arrived.
What did you get Fade?
You guys are okay right?
I am looting.
One is here.
I am going to say hello to him.
Oh there are people to my right.
I heard people looting to my right.
Right here?
We got one of them.
Yeah this guy is right here.
Oh he tried me.
Holy fuck.
He is inside.
I want to kill you.
Oh I cracked the other one.
I cracked the lifeline.
Yeah yeah yeah I cracked him.
I cracked him.
It is fine.
I have to reload.
There is one more.
There is a Gibby.
There we go.
Look at that.
I believe in you guys a lot.
Yeah I know.
I am just looting.
Holy shit.
That sounds delicious though.
Not gonna lie.
That sounds really good.
They are like fighting another squad.
Oh!
What they ran?
Are you kidding me?
Freaks!
They ran.
I am leaving.
Goodbye.
That is where they are.
They were on there.
They were in there.
But it is so... I am dead.
I am dead.
Okay.
There is another team here.
Look at these sweaty people.
Oh!
Goodbye.
I am so confused.
Oh no!
They are following me.
I was safe for one second.
I will pay for one second.
I am going to land into them.
We will die together.
You just landed into me.
I am alive.
That is so funny.
Freaks.
You are all freaks.
Take my shit.
Take all of it.
I don't even know what is going on.
I am the woman.
What the fuck?
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
It is okay.
Okay.
Alright.
I need to keep crawling.
That is not a problem.
Please just keep crawling.
This is our only hope.
No!
Wapig, no!
At least take his armor.
Yeah, I am going to take his armor.
And go for me and run.
Okay.
I don't know about that though.
I am not there.
What the fuck is this?
I don't even know.
What the fuck?
Why did I lose to you?
Smoke and run.
I should have just left you.
I should have just left you to die.
No.
You did it.
This is going to win us the game.
I hear them.
I hear people.
You were right.
Goodbye.
I am a gamer.
They won't notice you.
I have streamer power.
Shut up.
It is okay.
They will definitely notice me when I do this.
They were missing too.
I left.
Goodbye.
He is leaving.
He is not pushing.
He is running away.
He is guarding his teammates.
That is so cute.
I wish we had one of those.
I wish we had.
This is looted.
We might have a problem.
This entire area is looted.
You are even holding back.
I am good.
We might have a little problem.
This is looted.
I have a mask.
I have a Spitfire.
I am good.
I am so scared.
I am on a 9.
You are on a 9.
Try to find heals.
I have two batteries.
You want one?
Yes, I would like.
Oh Wapik.
I don't know if that is a good idea.
They are going to rev soon.
Oh no, not another rebel!
I think it's the same rebel.
Yeah, let's go.
Wapik, are you okay?
I am so far from you guys.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, I'm right... Tomato Town is right behind you.
I have ult, I have ult, don't worry.
I ulted.
They're queuing up, they're on you.
I ulted, I ulted, do not worry.
One hit for 50 on the move.
Okay, I missed every shot, do not worry.
One hit for 30 on the move.
Do not worry, I'm still missing every single shot.
I did not hit a shot.
Wait, they're getting shot at, this is a new team.
Yeah.
Bye.
I have left.
I have missed every single shot, do not worry.
I ran out of bullets.
What do you need?
I only have heavy.
I have energy, but I have a different gun.
I have no run of victory right now.
How about that?
I just missed every single shot.
Oh wow.
Alright, we can re-thread this.
We can re-thread this, like rank.
As if we're rank players.
As if we're good players.
I'm just taking my energy ammo.
Oh my god, what the fuck am I looking at?
What am I looking at?
This clusterfuck.
Okay, I can pick...
What the fuck?
Oh yeah, the cinnamon.
Wait.
Okay, no, I'm leaving.
No, no, no, they're rezzing, but they're gonna get the rezz off.
That's why I left.
Look, I got a blue armor too.
Is that the fucking April Fool thing?
That things just fall out of the sky and give you loot?
Yes.
And there's a Mozambique with more...
Golden Mozambique and a Golden 2020.
It's okay, we're fine.
How am I still kill leader?
I am still kill leader in this game.
I'm gonna rezz them right here.
Why am I still kill leader?
This is the second time, Wepic.
Second time.
This time I'll help you.
Do you believe me?
No.
Even I don't believe.
Then I don't have to.
You're right, because I'm a gamer.
I'm working some for my ex-king.
Naked and afraid.
It truly is.
Remember when you picked up the re-election?
We're gonna do it again.
I don't know how I've lived this long, chat.
I have like nothing.
Like no heals or anything.
I'm 33.
I've been like scrounging up armors.
I've just been like stealing armors from everyone.
Alright, we'll be okay.
We'll be okay.
I'm guarding him.
Simply run.
Only the gods can survive the clusterfuck.
It's like kindergarten.
This was looted.
There's a blue armor here for you.
I need like syringes.
I haven't found a single syringe.
Oh, I need that.
Oh, I found a medkit.
Alright.
Found a gold heavy mug.
Oh my god.
How am I still kill leader?
All I've been doing is running.
I don't know what's sadder.
Oh, I need that.
There's another recipe.
I can use it.
He just ran away.
That's why!
I can't.
True.
It gets kills by simply existing.
Oh, way too...
I have not felt like Wavagastic being dead properly.
You think I'd actually pick up your mobile or respawn it.
I'm beacon though, I'll just run away.
I'll use this for Wapig.
That's to the dream.
We haven't found any other people since we started running.
I see people.
Alright Wapig, be careful.
I'm just flying into them.
Wapig wait for us!
Wapig just wait for us Wapig!
Wait for us!
Is he stimming back?
Is he stimming back to us?
Where is he?
Where are they?
Oh...
There they are.
Alright let's go.
I'm ready to pick up your banners guys.
He's right on the respawn beacon.
Even if MRB doesn't take it, he still doesn't take it.
This guy just attacks game and attacks.
Might or might on the respawn beacon.
No, he's not.
He's right here.
Three times a charm guys.
I'm almost here guys.
I'm almost here.
That's not mine.
I can't shoot them because they decided to start crafting.
So I can't see them.
Well I might be...
I couldn't run from that!
Holy fuck.
I'm stunned.
Oh that's the last guy.
Where is he?
I'm a gold Mozambique guys.
Where is the guy that's chasing you?
Probably just chasing me.
No he's not.
I was trying to find him.
Oh where did you see him?
New team, new team, new team.
Oh I had a 416.
You know I'm just gonna run.
I'm just gonna run and heal.
Yeah I'm going too.
I'm hitting people.
Oh I cracked people to my left.
I cracked like a ton of people over here.
They're shooting each other.
Yeah they're like super low.
I'm still kill leader.
Oh my god.
There's two guys over there.
Oh my god stop!
Well they're both cracked.
Yeah they are.
This guy's not cracked you liar.
He was cracked.
I got hit in the troop.
Well there's only one guy.
It's only one guy yeah.
He's right here.
I think he's controller.
He's like mega beamed.
You're fine you're mega.
What the fuck?
What are these sevens though?
He got this!
Look at that.
Wait they rez!
I'm gonna leave you.
You have gold armor.
Gold armor.
Gold armor?
I love you.
Where?
Up above.
He's one.
That guy's low.
You're solo though.
What the fuck there's another team shooting him.
No that's Wapig.
No the other guys are rezzing.
The other guys are rezzing.
There was a scan from over there.
Wapig's got this.
I don't have a secondary gun.
Oh what the hell?
There he is.
Yeah.
He's low.
Where?
Oh I'm gonna shot him to my left.
I got him.
I don't know where the Wraith is.
I don't have a secondary gun.
This is like my warm up game.
I don't know where the Wraith went.
Oh there she is.
Is it a Wraith?
Yeah.
I thought it was a low bomb.
Oh well.
Oh my god how did we live?
What the fuck?
How did we live?
We did it.
Oh here's the gold P20.
Where's the gold P20?
Oh did you take it?
Oh.
Oh my god look at all these...
Yeah I gotta take this mose down too.
Is it tomato power?
Yeah there's one team left.
I'm gonna let him.
Where's the last team?
Ellie!
Thank you so much for the subscription!
To tier one!
Thank you!
Can we get some work done?
Oh by the way...
I don't think Doki's healed up.
Oh shit!
I was not!
The one died.
Oh shit.
No this is...
Knock one of them.
I ulted right side.
Oh.
I'm gonna hug you.
This is my ult.
Oh.
Here's the last guy.
We're gonna see.
What?
I can't see anything cause someone threw a grenade.
Oh me too.
I have... He's one though.
He's dead.
Oh!
Hey buddy.
Heyyyyy.
No!
I didn't shoot him.
I didn't hit him.
You fuck.
I saw a P20.
I saw a P20 in my system.
Yeah but I didn't hit him.
I did not hit him.
I didn't lock the gate.
It's time to be a tomato.
I should have just inted.
I should have picked you guys up.
It's time.
It's tomato time.
Alright that was a good first game actually.
I have not played Apex in so long.
I was whipping shots all around.
But I guess it's time to be a tomato.
Alright guys.
Let me unzip my skin suit real quick.
I am not.
Let me unzip my skin suit for you guys.
Alright.
Okay guys.
More frames.
It's tomato time.
Let's look it go.
I have unzipped the skin suit.
It was getting way too sweaty down there.
It was getting...
I can't do it, Heartfelt.
I don't have it here.
I don't have it set up for Apex.
I'll do it later, okay?
You know what?
What is a nice tomato character, guys?
Thank you so much in the rain.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
I am a tomatobetuber.
What did you do?
What do you mean?
We all have a tomato inside us.
Just unzip yourself, you liars.
Perfect rain timing.
This rain timing was impeccable.
This is the tomato within...
Wrong rate stream tomato.
What do you mean?
Guys, we all have a tomato inside of us.
You guys want to see me do a little shimmy?
My dance at tomato town.
Oh, I'm dead.
Mr. Tomato is dead.
I'm dead.
This game is garbage.
What happened?
I clicked the R9 and...
It's okay!
I'm alive!
The tomato is alive!
Do you want to play?
I have no heals.
No shields.
I'm very confused and scared why I'm enjoying it exactly.
Don't worry, I'm farming damage.
Naked and afraid, that's all we are.
How much can you make the tomato dance?
I'll do it for free.
100.
I'm not gonna...
Pop, pop, pop!
This guy?
Okay, there we go.
Thank you so much for the follow, Zinian HNXpired.
Thank you, thank you, and Poseidon.
Thank you so much!
This tomato is gaming!
I'm a tomato gamer.
Wait, is everyone dead?
Where are they?
Oh, okay.
I was...
I was dancing.
What the f...
That's those balls.
Yeah, but they...
It's like a mirage ball, basically.
This is gaming!
This is true gaming experience!
What the f...
I mean...
I think they're like at salvage or something.
I'm gonna go to 20.
I need like heals.
Our gamers unite.
I got the sweet times for you.
One of you guys.
So, do they just appear at random?
Make your tomato sweat so much you can feel not one, but two last swimming pools.
Exactly.
I am coming over.
Hey, senor!
Welcome to tomato gaming.
I am... I fucked up my looting.
Oh, weaponry is so far already.
I was confused.
I thought he was with us.
Why are you a tomato?
Why am I not a tomato?
Our servants got a tomato farm for a reason!
I am a tomato farm.
Would you guys swim in a swimming pool that's just filled with tomato juice?
How the tomato juice was obtained, I will never tell.
I will follow Daniel.
Thank you, thank you.
So, why isn't there a hammer point on the pit lane?
Why are you a tomato?
Exactly.
Wait, did you kill all of them?
Oh, oh, no, no, no.
What?
He didn't.
Oh, oh, I got one!
Bye!
I believe.
I don't have any heals.
I have to fucking get armor real quick.
This shit is broken.
What the hell?
So this P20 is actually broken.
We all shed our skin suits.
We're all tomatoes.
Shed that skin suit!
What do you need skin for?
It's time to embrace tomato.
No!
Are you ready to bar the tomato from me?
He's my cousin.
Three times removed.
What the fuck is this?
Cause it's April Fools.
25 damage per shot.
The mage is just stretching out tomato children.
I'm just gonna grab a second P20.
Shed the skins, embrace the tomatoes.
Oh!
Wait, what the fuck?
I'm gonna kill you.
No!
What the fuck?
How dare you?
I am a tomato.
Get punched by a tomat.
See if you can get 8x7.
Did he have friends?
I have no idea.
Did I thirst him?
No, no, he died.
I wanted to go for this fight.
Why he's skin suit?
Oh fuck.
I don't know, I saw that.
No you didn't.
So I get 25 bullets.
And each bullet does 25 damage.
What?
What is?
Are you talking about the P20 or the bozom?
Gotta drink chug jugs of tomato V8 to become a true gamer.
Just eat your tomato children.
I'm running double tweet P20 right now.
It's so stupid.
It's called survival of the fittest.
Every child...
Every tomato child I eat I get stronger.
I am.
Two of them.
Wait, on my right.
He's hiding in the corner.
What the fuck?
How to shoot bad guys.
I'm so far.
That's it.
Dude is literally above you.
One guy left.
Yeah, I got him.
Pop.
I just think he's onto the prime.
Can we get some fun things real quick?
Look how the pack is like getting rid of it out there.
Can we get some fun things real quick for us?
I like the suppose that Wapix said I know, I know.
And then he just comes down and dies.
Yeah, cause there's another fucking guy just hiding in the corner.
Like what the fuck?
All these corner sittings.
He wasn't batting.
Tomato emotes after pining.
Of course we're gonna have tomato emotes.
You think I'm an amateur?
I looked at him.
He's just sitting there in R3-1 and he doesn't move after he shot me.
Like a normal human being.
No, he's just sitting there.
It's okay.
We're here now.
He's gone.
The Batman's gone now.
He can't hurt you no more.
Don't get on Doki's show.
You're tomato children.
I'm playing like this.
Doki's looking at you like it's normal.
You like what you see guys?
You like what you see?
Should I take off my human suit more often?
Why am I running into the zone?
I love my little shimmy too.
I think that's my favorite part.
When I take off my skin suit.
I love the little shimmy I can do for you guys.
Maybe it'll be a tinier tomato.
Oh shit.
That's where they are.
He's like...
He made a portal for his teammates.
Don't worry guys!
He's flesh.
Don't worry I have speed.
Oh he hit me.
He hit me!
That's illegal.
Here's to him for me.
I don't like this.
So much...
All that flash.
But you forgot that blood in all games is just tomato ketchup.
So technically you're killing your brethren.
So?
I eat my brethren too.
Watch out for the big one.
That's what they get in the name of tomato finisher.
I don't know.
Looking pretty saucy there.
Thanks.
It's called tomato juices.
Tomato juice camel is the right stuff.
Every tomato I consume might get stronger.
Feed your children to me.
Become tomato reduce hitbox income bro.
I'm not a U-turn.
Well it's not really a U-turn.
We're so of I'm right behind you guys but 30 seconds away.
Human doki is a thief.
Tomato doki is a cannibal.
Why not both?
I can be both.
I'm trying to keep up with Wapik but he keeps stimming.
Of course.
How am I doing so well right now?
I am not paying attention to my game.
I have a keep 20 and a Mozambique.
Maybe as soon as I take out my weapon.
My skin suit.
I get stronger.
Who would have thought?
I guess I was getting too hot in there.
It's tomato.
Where are the needles and meatballs?
Wait guys!
Tomat is coming.
They're like over there.
Wait.
I was shooting the wrong guy.
Wait I'm getting shot by a new team.
There's a new team.
I only have smalls.
Yeah but there's a new team.
I'm ulting that team to the left.
Doesn't it look great that the level 21 with the Spitfire wins?
I don't know if they rez though.
He has a Spitfire.
I don't know.
I downed one guy but I think they rez.
Oh yep I downed him.
Oh!
You killed the Spitfire.
Don't worry you're fine.
Yeah!
I'm going to go with the Spitfire.
Crack this guy.
Give me a second.
Well we're having a redo.
It's just I'm showing my true form.
Okay I'm queuing up.
I'm going to rest my ass.
Isn't that how we do it?
Yeah I'm coming with you guys.
I want to be safe too.
I want to feel safe.
Oh there's another team.
Yeah I downed one guy from one of the team.
Tomato kill leader!
The power of tomato VTubers.
Okay Wapik I'm going for it.
But yeah we're all tomatoes.
Everyone wants some potatoes.
Fake tomatoes.
Maybe I should become tomato.
Then I'll truly be cracked at Apex.
What if we're all tomatoes all along though?
You just gotta take off your skin suit guys.
Or come work at my tomato farm.
And then you can be as good as Apex like me.
Take off your skin suit.
It's like the Adamo move where a character was wearing weights and removes them.
You might want to grab a mastiff.
Nah I'm fine.
The era of C-Tubers is over.
It's vegetable tubers now!
Oh that's the guy we killed.
I killed earlier.
I told you it's fine.
Give yourself a big and red one.
What?
I'm going to kill you guys.
Are we going to push that?
Yeah sure.
Alright you go first.
VeggieTales were the first vegetable tubers.
Oh I hear them.
They almost fucked on me.
It's right here.
I don't know if they're going to come out.
Holy shit!
He cheated!
No!
He's angry because I killed him last time.
He cheated!
He's going to take my shit!
Alright Wapig is gone.
Wapig is...
How dare they get...
How dare they get high ground!
I live on the...
I can't reach that.
I'm so sorry.
I'm going to be part of the fruit gang.
God damn!
Fake vegetables!
I just gotta return...
Alright Merino!
Alright Rez me!
Rez me!
Where is the tomato?
Hold on...
We don't need Wapig.
We can win this without him.
Wapig is going to come in and die.
This thing is...
This thing is skying people in their life.
Damn.
Feed me more- Don't worry chat, you feed me more tomato children.
I'll get bigger.
It's hard living that rooted life of a vegetable.
Truly is.
But I gotta get ready.
Alright!
Alright Omni, thanks for hitting all of us!
Even though you were just looking, thank you!
I hope you have a good night's rest.
Have a good stream, thank you!
I hope you have a good night's rest, Omni.
Tomato capitalism to enhance the power, exactly.
Why do you think I have a tomato farm?
I eat my children.
Only the strongest tomato can survive, exactly.
Survival of the fittest was created just for tomatoes like me.
I'm gonna get armor, real quick.
Alright, I have...
Dumb guns right now.
Well, I have an RE45, it's alright.
To be cracked at APC, you pass a tomato trap, eating all your brethren.
Exactly.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Has no one- Has no squad died yet since I got rez?
Nope.
They just keep rezzing each other.
It's really weird.
Woah, woah, wee, woah!
It's like that.
Maybe the damage farm is on the shore.
Damage farm?
Damage farm is in the pub.
Oh wait, no, of course you- Oh wait, never mind.
Everyone damage farms in the pub.
Gotta queue down, gotta queue down and it's like really low.
I'm just leading a bit more.
Do not worry!
I have nothing!
I'm gonna take this.
Oh, it's Suki!
It's Suki-chan!
It's a full box there now.
Alright, they're fighting.
The last two teams are fighting.
Yeah, take that box, take that box, take that box.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
We gotta go to the last squad after.
Yeah.
Careful for your health.
Oh shit, my health.
Yeah, yeah, I'm medkitting it in.
You go in first, I'll clean up later.
Oh, they finished.
They finished.
I think it's a 1v3.
It's a 2v3.
I'm almost there.
Oh shit!
Wait, one's above, one's above.
They're all above.
They have 74 on them.
74 on the other- Oh no.
They're gonna heal.
Yeah, they're gonna heal, what the fuck?
I don't have any- I don't have any-
Oh, they're gonna rez...
I fucking knew it.
Fuck you guys.
Your yeast yourself, does that mean you keep going back and not gain any size?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I would anyone eat themselves?
I have a farm.
I'm never gonna run out of food.
Well, looks like we lost.
Hmm.
Do I go back?
I guess I have to put back my skin suit on because we didn't win.
Unfortunate.
Let me zip up my skin suit real quick chat.
Hey guys.
Hey everyone, what did I miss?
What did I miss chat?
No, my true tomato farm.
What do you mean?
This is my true farm.
What are you guys talking about?
Huh?
What are you guys talking about chat?
This is my true farm.
Huh?
You missed nothing.
Now you eat your slime.
This is a turkey.
I know.
What do you mean guys?
I've always been like this.
What are you guys talking about?
I have no idea what you guys are talking about.
There goes the tomato.
What are you guys talking about chat?
I've always been like this.
Huh?
Who is this bot when I recognize nothing?
What do you mean?
I've always been the dokiyano.
The thief.
Right?
The thief that for some reason owns a tomato farm.
Because she does honest living.
Nope, she doesn't consume her children.
I make an honest living selling tomatoes.
Oh.
Who are you and what did you do to my tomato?
Oh, nothing in the back.
Alright, well looks like we need a win if we wanna unzip the skins.
Oh, well goodbye.
I got one of them.
Alright, I'm coming guys.
Don't worry.
Do not worry.
I'm almost there.
Are you rising yet?
There is only one.
Oh.
I did it.
There is armor here.
I think they are on the other side.
Yeah.
I don't... I didn't get the kill.
Why did he crawl?
Oh, there he is.
Twitch.
Yo-Yo.
There are people on me.
Alright, I'm rotating.
Rotating.
They are like here.
They are here too.
On the outside.
Yeah.
I'm gonna see if I can get them to...
60.
Cracked him.
Behind here.
They are like outside.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
Right here.
1HP.
1HP on this kit.
Peek me.
Oh, he didn't peek me.
He knew.
He is not fun.
Come on.
Oh, okay.
Fuck you.
Alright, I'm coming to you guys.
Nice.
His teammate is right here with me.
Is this the song of the century here in the bag?
Banana LG.
I don't even know what song he is playing to be honest.
Oh, he is right here now.
Where are you running, sir?
Sir?
Why are you running?
I think he is going to get his banner.
Sir?
I hear him.
Is he pressing?
Inside?
Oh, no.
He is so dead.
Wait.
Hey, sir.
I wasn't good.
Wait.
Where is he going?
He is running.
He is like a...
Wait.
He has...
He has teammates.
He has teammates?
He has friends?
Above us, it is a different team now.
Wait.
What?
He had purple armor, didn't he?
Yeah, he did.
And now he doesn't.
Well, how am I looking at?
How does he...
Where did his purple armor go?
On my body!
Wait, did you have blue?
Yeah, it's on my body.
I earned it.
Oh, shit.
There's a...
Where is his friends?
I don't know, but I'm gonna get this golden archery one in this middle.
What are those?
Will we ever find his friends?
And it doesn't pick up.
That's my favorite feature about this game.
Wait, I need... wait, this gold mozant doesn't have a hop-up?
No, but it still does like 500 damage.
Oh, shit, really?
Oh.
Oh, wait, I hear people read this way.
The P20.
The P20 doesn't have a hop-up, but it does 25 damage per shot.
Yeah, yeah.
We only use gold mozams.
So it's like hammer points without the hammer points.
I'm so lost where the other person is.
Yeah, I'm so lost where his friends are.
I'm just living for the other squad.
We need...
Give us... chat, give me your strength so we can be reborn as a... so I can take off my skin suit.
Every game we win, I take off the skin suit.
They're like above.
Let's go this way.
I hear map room.
I hear map room scan graphic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm going over now.
Wait, you're going to the other squad?
Yeah, cause they're fighting.
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll go over there.
I don't wanna one-way tree, so I'll just go, I guess.
I think it was great.
We...
Why not?
We consumed some tomato children.
No, I stopped shooting.
Fuck.
Yes.
Fluffy, yes.
Flutters seems to release the tomato.
Wow, I just can't aim.
Not yet tomato doki yet.
Okay, by the time we get there... Oh, no!
You got killed by a TTPer!
They didn't swap my guns, instead they just punched.
Is he up there?
No, I think he shot him from below.
Oh, yep, never mind.
Quacked him.
I ulted.
Smoking.
Mmm, I hear the octane.
Get up there.
I don't know where...
I don't know, I'm sticking to it.
Take it, take it, take it, I got it.
He's low, yeah?
I'm gonna heal now.
Bye.
Derset, Derset him.
Wait, he took the zip out.
He took the zip out.
Cracked the bus house.
Do not worry, sirs!
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
Where did his teammate go?
Downstairs.
I guess he's... yeah, he's downstairs.
Yeah, he's downstairs.
Yeah, I'm gonna loot.
I hear him healing.
He's healing.
He's right here.
Or was that my shadow?
No, no, he's inside healing somewhere.
Woo, where are you?
He's somewhere here.
I'm like, looking everywhere.
I'm in a Twitch stream right now.
He finally left.
I'm over here trying to make friends, and he just doesn't want to make friends.
He does not.
He's crazy, that's why.
He's crazy.
Like, I look at him, T-bag, and then he's like, nope, I shoot you.
You'll get friends eventually, Wapiki, you'll get friends eventually.
I'm just kidding.
That octane was crazy though.
Like, can you get in the game?
What server are you playing?
Because any servers are usually populated.
I don't understand people.
I'm not shooting them, I'm just looking at them.
Yeah, but he's like, I'm bringing you down with me.
What is he gonna do?
Stay with you?
One more kill.
I was gonna let him live.
I don't think he...
I think he wanted to just leave.
I think he just...
I was not gonna tell you guys about him.
I was just gonna be like, oh, he's gone, and make sure he doesn't get discovered.
I have like, uh, I have only syringes in my fucking backpack.
Oh, here, take three batteries.
I need like, shield cells.
Here, two bats and four shield cells.
Oh yeah.
Oh yeah, I need that.
Please feed me.
Yeah, yeah.
All the heals.
Oh my, it's been so long since I've caught a stream.
Chaos!
I am level 47.
I'm level... I don't even know what level I am.
I've maxed out a long time ago.
I used to be just fine with my, uh, laptop.
Yeah, but like, Apex requires...
Apex is like, so heavy intensive.
Like, GPU and CPU intensive.
Is that a new level?
It is, cause the game came out a while ago.
So, hi flu!
The game came out a while ago, so a lot of people are like, maxed out levels.
Cause it's been like, what, two years?
It's on season 8 now.
I don't know.
Yeah, you can be like, high level and still be garbage at it.
I've bumped into a lot of level 500s who are not the best at this video game.
But they're having a good time, and that's all that matters.
They're up here.
Oh, I hear them.
But no, like, um...
Oh, they're still fighting.
Well, you got one in them.
I am...
Wapig, do not worry!
I'm not.
Do not worry, Wapig!
This is two squads.
Thank you.
Where's that caustic?
Oh, he's in here.
I cracked it.
He's cracked.
Yeah.
They're like, to my right.
Oh, he's in here.
I ulted the people to the right.
There's a rappel coming in.
He's dead, but I need...
I got the armor swap.
Don't worry, I'm cracking the people to the right.
I cracked these guys.
One where?
Oh, this is a different team.
There's a team right here, though.
Flash on one of them.
Be careful of the team to our right.
I'll push with...
I'll push with acid.
Oh, I messed up my thermite.
Wap!
Wait, what?
Where did he go?
Wait, where is his teammate?
Oh!
What the fuck?
Where is he?
Oh.
What the fuck?
Wait, I'm blocking this.
Where is he?
Below?
Oh.
I need help.
He's one, he's one, he's one!
Ah!
Yeah, we're a bit fucked, though.
I'm gonna drop down here.
I wanna see him control with my body.
Maybe my intake is just...
It's impossible to have just one PC.
No, it's possible.
You need like a really good graphics card.
And a really good CPU.
Um, it's possible if you don't want...
Not really good in terms of GPU and CPU, but like...
Well, I have my model on, so I need like good shit for it.
But even I get heavy frame drops.
Cause I drop from 200 to 100.
Um...
So, play to have fun.
Yeah, play to have fun.
Alright, I'm full of you.
Get it.
They're up there, right above us.
Alright, that's unfortunate.
I'm taking some names.
Oh, whoa!
I-I- You pick them up!
Cause I'm leaving.
Then mine can go from 60 to 500.
Ah, console, I see.
They're gonna follow!
Tryzora, ApexGamer, and PS4 account.
They're gonna kill!
They're here.
Aw, they're like camping.
I have heat shields.
Oh, I do not have heat shields.
Do you have heat shields?
Is that the Duel Keeper?
It is!
This zone is okay, right?
Yeah, it's second.
I don't have a lot of realize.
I don't have Medkit, but that's fine.
We can res him...
We have to res him here.
Wow.
I don't have a mobile resp you can hear.
Nope.
Maybe one of these freaks had one.
No, they didn't.
They're here, they're here.
I hear them.
Wait, I think they're fighting.
Yeah, they're fighting.
To my left.
Dugol!
Thank you so much for the...
Two months, two months tier one.
I can't... English hard.
Two months tier one!
Thank you!
Can I get some Farknights real quick?
Haha, for Dugol.
Thank you, thank you!
I'm just gonna go res.
Yeah, cause they're fighting right now over here.
Alright.
Yeah, they're just like...
They're fighting right here.
I'm just trying to Apex-y.
Hahaha!
Thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you, thank you!
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
My games are just fun how the F is just not able to play on my laptop.
I make 3D games.
It's just Apex is very...
Not very optimized very well.
It's like very unoptimized.
That's why a lot of people play Apex but they don't stream it.
Because it's like your frames die very...
Like...
You get very shit frames when you try to.
Unless you have a good PC setup.
But like, even I like...
No, I'm good.
Yeah.
This isn't looted.
So...
It should be okay here.
There's like loot here.
There's a blue arm here.
I'm coming over.
Knock one.
I am almost here.
Where's his teammate?
Down there.
45 on the caustic.
I hear...
Bloodhound.
I'm burning one of them.
Bloodhound's burning.
Oh shit!
I thought that was you!
That's last guy.
Caustic maxed.
Yeah.
There we go.
Nice.
There's like stuff for you here.
I had a Spitfire.
I was okay.
No yeah, Apex run perfectly fine.
Maximum even while streamed.
But you wanna lowest on stream.
Yeah, you just can't...
It's very hard to run it with stream stuff.
Last two teams are fighting, right?
Yeah.
I'm just...
I'm just trying to Apex.
Oh no.
He pinged them Wapix.
So I can throw my ult.
Oh.
Well then.
My ult is on them.
On me.
Smoke him.
I smoked him.
Yeah, they're running.
Oh, they're on me.
What the fuck?
Stop dying!
They're on me.
I got one of them.
Last guy.
I have that team.
Yeah, you died to zone.
Where's the other team?
There.
Is that the full control?
It is?
That's unlucky.
And they have double Spitfire.
Alright.
Let's just rez Wapix.
Wait.
There's no more rez Vigains.
I'm going to Map Room right now.
I'll rez him.
We're going Map Room?
Okay.
We gotta rez him.
Wait.
You don't have to go.
I'll go Map Room and rez him.
And then I'm ditching him after that.
Just stay alive.
Try to push updates constantly.
There's a lot of bugs in Apex that they haven't fixed at all.
Like the rank bugs.
There's so many bugs in Apex that they haven't really fixed.
But they're just like...
Well.
We're still making money.
That's alright.
I think it's not just Apex.
A lot of developers do that.
As long as they're still making money.
Oh.
They're pushing Wapix I think.
I'm going to smoke them.
You're going to land it over here.
I'm going to close zone.
Oh.
You want to fight?
Oh no.
We're clocked dead.
Yeah.
I'm clocked dead.
I hit him for 55.
I got one of them.
Yeah.
I'm self-resing.
With the ball backpack.
Yeah.
But I think they might curse you.
Wait.
He's behind me?
What the fuck?
I'm trying to get back to you.
How is he behind me?
I'm coming back.
I dropped down accidentally.
Oh.
Okay.
Well I finished one of them.
I'm trying to Apex.
I can't see him too.
I hit 75 on him.
Oh shit.
What the fuck.
I'm dead.
Wait.
What?
I didn't know he was above me.
Peek me.
Come on.
I know you want to peek me.
Oh.
He's not.
He's trying to...
Yeah.
He got your armor swap.
I'm dead then.
Yeah.
Oh.
He got your armor swap.
That was... Ah.
That was close.
That was close though.
I was fucking fragging.
My aim was really on point that game which is nice.
That's all me bros.
It's like how Fortnite caters very heavily to little children to buy their skins.
It's like...
It's not just Apex.
It's every other AAA game that can earn money.
Like how they keep making skins of very very many very big streamers and be like, hey guys buy my skin.
And then the children, kids are like Oh my god!
You're my favorite streamer!
I'm gonna buy your skin!
And then bam.
We don't have to care about anything else.
Hahahaha
I played Apex for the first time yesterday and seen Doki play Serial.
Now that I understand a little more about the game.
See the zoom.
It says, wow because I can stream hard find.
That game looks amazing.
Yeah.
It's just Apex in general.
Um.
It's just not optimized for the thing.
Hahaha
So I need like a very powerful rig.
Not very powerful, just a very good rig.
Just to stream Apex and have my model on.
And also and also be able to pew pew win Apex.
That's why you see a lot of YouTubers that just run PNGs.
Because like they rather just like have like good frames instead of um instead of like you know pew pew instead of like having the model on.
Okay.
Can't wait for tomato Doki skin in Fortnite.
We almost got our tomatoes tomato form back.
Also thank you so much for the follow Pineapple.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I'm ready.
I'm going to fly over to there now.
There was a team here but they Oh, is there?
No, not anymore.
They saw the pro trails and were like fucked up.
You guys want to see where they make the games more parable to play on lower end PC?
Yeah, this is unfortunate.
Maybe I should use my shitty Apex to stream the game but play the game on my PC that might work.
Yeah, yeah.
I see them.
I'm going to snipe that.
I just got sniped at by... Oh, okay.
Why does he...
What the fuck?
Flash.
Well, I can't do anything about that.
Well, okay.
I thought you were going to be...
You know what?
It's alright.
It's okay.
This might be dumb.
But it's...
Okay, it's not dumb.
It was so smart.
He's cracked.
Last guy is over here though.
Yeah, I'm just going to back up.
No.
No, there's another team.
There's another team on us.
I have... There's another team over here.
Oh, yeah.
You're right.
The bubble disappeared.
It's okay.
He doesn't know.
Idiot!
Alright.
I am safe.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I heard there was a lot of problems with the switch port.
Why are you still alive?
Oh, what the fuck?
Alright, he's kidding me right now.
Why is there a body here?
What the fuck?
Why are you here?
I mean...
Oh, that's not hot.
Oh, there's a full... Oh!
Oh!
There's two squad that redeployed to me.
Oh, okay.
I'm dead.
I just got redeployed.
It's okay.
Yeah, yeah.
That's what I'm doing.
Bring them over.
They're still looting my body anyway.
Yeah!
Bye!
They're gonna take forever looting this.
Oh, my God.
Where is that other team?
You know, fuck this.
I don't wanna die to a controller team.
I'm... Bye.
I'm not letting them kill me!
No, you're saying it's too good to die to a controller team.
Yeah.
Yes, I am.
God, I dash.
Hope everyone has a good day.
And don't eat too many other tomato presents.
Can't stop me!
Good night, though.
I really appreciate you stopping by and hanging out with us today.
Hope you have a good rest of the night.
Thank you, thank you!
Hey, Viva!
I'm gonna stream for like...
I think around like...
3 or so minutes.
And we're gonna call it here.
I told you guys it was gonna be short.
It is gonna be a short stream today.
Hi, Juki!
Let's hope we get like another win.
So we can be our true selves.
Do you speak Japanese?
I do not.
I apologize.
I'm very bad at Japanese.
I speak a lot of other languages, but Japanese isn't one of them.
Learning languages is just very hard.
She's amazing at French.
Ah!
Bonjour!
No, I swear.
I'm actually decent at French.
Ahahaha!
Otogi only speaks Wee.
Nope!
Only wins!
No, I'm not.
I'm not.
Unfortunately not.
I speak English, French, Chinese, both Cantonese and Mandarin.
And um...
And a bit of Korean.
But not Japanese.
Japanese is a very, very, very hard language to learn.
And um...
I just...
I just need to find the time to learn it.
Bunker, bunker, bunker.
I need to get like a tutor.
I think like Japanese, you have to get a tutor to learn that language.
Just because there's so many rules.
And like so many...
Um...
Yeah, but I grew up with Chinese though.
I grew up learning Chinese from...
My parents.
So that was fine.
But like...
Especially at such an old...
Like you know...
Such a late age.
I destroyed their...
Secret thingy.
I do not know which one.
This one!
This is low, this guy is low.
Weapon!
Behind you!
He's low.
Um...
Writing Chinese is too good.
To actually learn Japanese you lived or use it.
Yeah, yeah.
Same with Chinese too.
I think if I had to learn Chinese now.
If I didn't know Chinese at all and had to learn it now.
I would be...
I would give up.
A tutor like...
I think duolingo doesn't really help.
In terms of like...
In terms of like actually like...
Learning learning.
Learning learning in language.
I think like it's better to just...
Hire a tutor instead of like going through...
Duolingo.
Because I think duolingo is just like an extra bonus thing.
That you can do for like you know just to...
Brush it up after your lessons.
Are you...
Are you a Chinese?
I'm Canadian.
I was like...
Are you a Chinese?
I'm Canadian.
You sound funny when said Cantonese.
This is my second year living in Japan.
I can only do casual Japanese.
Conversational Japanese.
I'm struggling.
Business Japanese.
Yeah I heard like...
I heard like even like if you're like...
Even if you're like a fluent Japanese speaker.
Like you're still learning Japanese.
You're still learning too.
It's still hard.
For like even native speakers in Japan.
Also thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I think I might be getting sick but I hope you end on a...
Oh boy!
Take care of yourself.
I hope... Get better.
Get better soon.
Get better.
I just get confused if Chinese people can kind of understand.
Because Japanese but it just confuses me.
Chinese has so much shit in terms of kanji.
In terms of just how...
A ton of American...
American...
No no it's a separate country.
America is the state of Canada.
I don't know if you guys know that.
What um...
Oh you guys are inside.
There's a team right...
There's two teams up here.
Why can't my dad have me learning Latin or ancient Greek.
I feel cheated.
Don't worry guys.
There's a team outside.
There's a team out...
Are you bringing them?
Are you bringing them with you?
No no of course not.
No I would never.
Where is your white speed?
Is there any armor here?
On the box maybe.
Oh I found one.
I don't have my jump.
In there you don't know like a language thing.
I'm gonna roll with...
Where?
Oh shit.
I'm getting shot by a different guy.
Where's your guy?
Oh right here.
Oh okay.
Nice.
Above us?
Oh shit yeah yeah.
There's a guy heading to...
On me too.
Yeah yeah yeah.
This is like a...
I...
Oh...
There's so many different teams here.
I don't know what to do.
I might be dead.
Yeah.
Oh this guy is cracked.
Oh nice.
Okay yeah well yeah.
Even English is very hard.
Yeah if you're not a native English speaker.
It's very very hard too.
Like English is such a difficult language.
Is he shot by a zheng?
BITCH!
Oh please have some funk acid.
How dare you!
That's fucked up.
That's fucked up!
I hope they kill you and I don't rez you.
Cause can you neighbor is too shiny.
Not right now though!
English has like the dumbest rules too.
You know what?
Yeah fuck it.
I heard the damage is a lot too.
Okay I just think...
No no.
Korean is one of the easiest languages in the world to learn.
Um if you want to learn a new language.
Other than like if you only speak one language.
And you want to learn a new language that's not Korean.
Like I mean...
I mean if you want to learn a new language.
And you don't speak Korean.
Uh...
Korean is actually one of the easiest languages to learn right now.
Also the easiest language is the phone Matt.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you!
Where do we go?
Oh I'm in the phone.
Oh okay.
Yeah exactly.
Yeah that's why.
What?
They're just chilling.
I wouldn't call it chilling.
Oh my god!
I got one of them.
I can't climb this.
I don't know if I'm safe though.
I think he's going to follow.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
I'm gonna shield sell real quick and then help you.
I'm heading over.
This is the last guy.
Cracked.
I heard a charge rifle team.
Get over here.
Woo!
Bye!
I leave.
I hide in house.
That wasn't even the crypto team.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Um.
Cause like the emperor.
No no no.
I heard a crypto ult just then.
Because of like the emperor.
The ruler of Korea.
I went to his grave.
I have no light ammo.
Does anyone have light ammo to spare?
No.
I have like zero light bullets right now.
I hit his 16.
Light ammo here.
Why are you so good?
Oh thank you.
Well that's not true.
I can't 16 more.
Yeah I went to like his temple area.
To learn more about his history.
But yeah they.
They purposely.
Um.
Made the language very very easy to learn.
Where is Wraith?
Octane hit for 40.
I almost cracked him.
Octane cracked.
Okay I'm gonna take the jump pad.
Where is his teammate?
Oh right here.
There's two here.
I thought he was dead.
Last guy is right here.
Haha he's so dumb.
You were sniping me.
For some unknown reason.
My aim today is really good.
Where is my 4-8?
Which is surprising.
Because usually on stream it's not.
I tried learning Swedish.
I quit 2 but it doesn't seem hard compared to other languages.
I think.
Oh.
Swedish is very hard to learn in terms of speaking Swedish.
Got
one of them.
Oh shit.
Wait what the fuck?
Dead.
That was good.
Bop.
I tried learning Swedish for a while.
Thank you so much for the follow bros.
I do appreciate it.
Thank you.
I think like.
Swedish is very hard to pronounce.
Like I can't do a lot of like.
European languages.
Because European languages.
Is very hard for me to pronounce in terms of like.
Tongue movements.
Cause like you gotta move your tongue in a specific way.
And I'm like.
I can't even roll my R's.
I can't do.
I can't roll my R's.
That was me attempting to roll my R's.
And you gotta be able to roll.
Use the.
That's me rolling R's.
Oh those sounds.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
Don't roll your R's.
Language is one of the hardest.
Like languages is very hard to learn.
Especially the older you get.
So sign it off with bird like.
You gotta be like.
You know you gotta learn young.
Cause the older you get.
The harder it is to learn a language.
Cause your brain is already developed.
Unless.
I mean my.
My brain stopped developing after a certain.
After.
Elementary school but.
But.
Wait where are they?
Last time I saw them.
They went in the bunker.
They're in bunker?
I'm gonna read the play over.
I'm going to the lifeline package.
Lifeline package where?
Here?
My son said.
Malaysia easy learning.
And somehow I took 10 years learning the formal version of my mother tongue.
I assume it's a lifeline package.
Cause there was nothing in the radar.
Here.
Right in front of you.
Crack one of them.
I hit 20 on the other.
I'm trying to get closer.
I'm getting closer to you.
Hey there.
Haha.
Cracked Octane.
Octane dead.
Where's your teammate?
Huh?
Oh he had a.
Okay.
Coming over.
I'm ulting.
I ulted.
This is my ult.
What are they?
Nothing!
Uh there two here were dead.
Coming over.
Yay I did it!
I contributed.
Woo!
We got a participation award!
Hmm, it's funny.
It's weird how people shame you for knowing more than one language because it's like Why would you shame someone for that?
It's like It's like look at this loser.
No, it not Look at this loser knowing more than one language.
Wow.
I Never understood people who do that It's like what do you mean?
Look at People shame for yeah people do he was shamed something like Like especially like kids like oh my gosh little kids are so mean I hear stories of Like no, it's like if you specially you live in like a predominantly English Neighborhood you'll be like look at this loser knowing more than one language
Yeah, I've heard stories about it like why my friends said that she doesn't like oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa She doesn't like speaking um Like because she knows like three languages to um Their parents are from her parents are from Malaysia.
Well, just like saying how like her friends are like Where are they?
I got his teammate Okay Wow
I got one person so I don't know if this is There's two teams here.
Two teams.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, I was gonna say yeah.
The other team is in here No, there's a guy right here
One I stole that one Ha ha ha Yeah, no but uh part of it is that you can just don't know all the words I often need to use the second language.
I really like the background music here.
Yeah, yeah, they're all up there.
Right here, I see them.
They're right there.
Poor guy!
Last guy, oh last guy!
If we win this, I'd be a tomato again!
Oh...
They both won.
I'm the third guy.
Alright, so... okay!
I ulted them.
58 on one of them.
I hit 180 and 160.
You're fine.
They're like running because of my ult.
Yeah, we just died, otherwise.
Yeah, I'm done minting.
What the fuck?
Why is that...
I'm dead.
Two, two, two, two, two.
Just two.
They're rezzing one guy.
The other guy is self-rezzed.
This guy is self-rezzed.
Self-rezzed, self-rezzed, right here.
Self-rezzed, self-rezzed.
He got it off, he got it off.
He's running.
He's healing, just heal, just heal, just heal.
It's an octane, it's an octane.
You're a tomato!
I'm a tomato!
That did it!
Tomato time!
Alright, this is gonna be my last game.
My tomato game will be my last game.
You're gonna have to go through with it.
Alright, now to take off my sweaty skin suit.
Alright guys, I'll be right back.
I need to take off my skin suit real quick, chat.
Be right back.
Hello.
The tomato is back.
I've consumed my children for today.
Tomato supremacy is here.
Thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I won't hide where the ketchup comes from.
It's from my kids.
It's okay guys, I'm just gonna go...
go die.
I swear at one point you'll be an anime dude.
I'll like your emotes.
It's time.
It's time to do a tomato dance too.
Pop pop.
Time to dance too.
Da da da da da.
No, you guys help me harvest my children.
That's why I have a farm.
And you are my farmers.
And my wardens.
Adios, adios!
Yes, the tomato shuffle.
The tomato shuffle.
That's my favorite.
Woah.
Bruh, I ironically want this tomato url to seem more of it.
Tomato dodging mode like, woo!
You know like that video of like that grandpa, like, dodging and moving?
Because, uh, when he's playing Overwatch, that's me when I play Apex.
Woo!
Can't kill me if I dodge!
Zeno, thank you so much for the follow!
Thank you!
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Yeah, we're gonna have, don't worry, we're gonna have a tomato model redeem.
Do not worry.
Alright, I'm worried because I only have a sentinel.
I have the guns I hate.
Are you okay?
I'm not okay.
I got one killed one and the other got...
Oh my god, they're all very low.
They're all very low.
They're all down here.
Where's the Wraith?
Where's the Octane?
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
He was next to you.
Yeah, I couldn't tell.
He's low, he's low.
I put you to the low.
I don't know why I'm a tomato.
I'm a tomato.
You can't trust me.
I'm ketchup.
I was not low in any world.
I was so confused.
I didn't know where he was.
It's okay, it's okay.
It brought you over.
Don't trust the tomato.
I eat my children and you want to trust me?
This one is trying to learn ISL.
That's time for like 20 indig...
Oh my gosh, that's a lot of English.
Someone's over there.
It's important to learn record time.
What do you mean joke?
I had this motto for four months.
There's no jokes about the tomato.
Oh, thank you.
People who have never watched you before are so confused.
They thought I was an actual tomato streamer.
Tomato Persian Pog.
Has science gone too far?
I don't have an angle on this guy.
There you go.
He just forgot where I was.
No, I think he got scared that I shot him.
Science has gone too far, but they can go even further.
How far can science go?
You know what?
I'm going to go extra scummy.
I'm going to get that Spitfire.
Time for extra scum.
Scum apex gamer.
You ever go out and publicize your skin suit?
I don't know.
Sometimes I want to go wild and like, get buried in other farms.
And steal their tomato children.
For my own.
You know, typical tomato things.
Seize the kill?
I eat my children?
Do you want Jesse?
I make my own angles.
Yeah, I steal other people's children.
That's why I go outside.
Oh, what?
Bullshit.
Oh, you wanted to steal that?
Was that it?
I pressed A on it.
Tomato lean enables.
The game was like, nah, mate.
Not only do I steal money, I steal other people's tomatoes.
There can only be one tomato farm.
Look at that tomato potty.
That is peak Apex performance.
Oh, I hear a shot above.
I have no idea where they are, but I heard a...
Pah!
Wherever that pump master is.
No more baby showers.
It's a boy, no, it's a me.
Time to go in my belly!
Capacitor.
It's like here, right?
It's a great time.
All my children's dream is to be in my belly.
So I can get stronger.
And tomato we did trust.
It would be exactly!
Exactly!
Faye knows what's up.
Oh, there's a fucking portal here.
Yeah, there's people that are like below here.
They jump out on these people.
I jump out on these people as well.
Oh, new team, new team, new team!
Oh, Revolts.
Behind you, behind you, Asa, new team behind you!
Oh, yeah, I got stuck.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm dead too.
Oh my gosh.
I have to like extra run.
I jumped out of the way Wapix, so I'm safe here.
Woo!
No, I'm not!
I am actually safe.
You jumped out of the way.
Yeah, because I got stuck.
No, fuck this.
Because I was sniping.
Oh, you're from damage?
I don't know, I almost downed a guy.
There is like another team on me.
That's right.
You're right, I'll survive that.
You don't know I'm a tomato on you.
I'm just growing on the ground.
I don't know.
I'm a perfect camouflage.
The perfect...
He knew.
No, he knew.
What the fuck?
What's wrong with you?
Tomato hater.
There's a tomato hater.
Are you here?
I'm not the perfect camouflage.
I got crushed.
I got killed by a hater.
You got you.
I got squashed.
What were the odds?
I thought you were down below.
There's people out there.
This guy.
He's just one guy.
Yeah!
Alright, pick my body up and then other person...
Holy fuck.
Are you okay?
I am back.
The tomato...
Tomato never dies.
What do you mean?
There's still one squad here somewhere.
Alright.
The tomato never dies.
Ow, snipe.
I shall be rebirthed.
I shall regrow from the ground.
Watch me grow again.
Watch this.
Watch this guys.
Watch it.
Woop.
Woop!
Inside...
There it is.
You may squish me.
There we go.
We're just like...
Someone ping me the boxes?
Gorshimisa.
Our nutrition has arrived.
You can never...
You can never fully squash a tomato.
A potato.
Alright, what do I get rid of?
Alright, there we go.
Two things are known in the livestreamers, never die.
They don't ever die, exactly.
I need to get this car mine and then...
So many gold items, dude.
Holy fuck.
I have returned.
My seeds on the ground has regrown a tomato.
I never die.
Someone's been over here.
Alright, I'm heading back.
I don't see him.
Look at that, 400... 400 damage!
I'm a 12!
I'm a true gamer!
The tomato never dies!
How does it feel to be immortal?
LOL Have you ever seen a dead tomato?
I think not.
Only consumed tomatoes.
Crypto.
Last two teams.
There it is.
Oh yeah, they're on the hangar and somewhere down below.
The hangar?
What?
The other thing, the 82 thing.
The diving board.
When people need a tomato, PC lives out.
Exactly.
The diving board, watchtower.
I accept watchtower, diving board.
This is weird.
Nah, it's a diving board.
Wait, so where are they?
Are we going here?
One is up here and one is down.
Oh, I am going where Wapik is cause Wapik will die if we don't.
I know.
Oh, Wapik instantly gets shot at.
Of course he gets shot at.
It's a terror.
Oh, he jumped down.
One of them.
He's here.
Can you shoot him?
He's down there.
No, he's not.
I don't see him.
Was it a clone?
I think so, yeah.
That's a real one?
What the fuck?
Alright, you gotta hurry.
You gotta hurry.
He got down.
Of course he got down.
I'm almost there.
Oh, I got galaxy brained.
Also...
I got one of them.
I don't know where his teammates are.
Oh, his teammates are here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
At the back.
I'm running.
Tomato!
Freedom!
There's like a team that's like...
There's a guy that has self-res in there.
Hate milk!
Yeah, but the guy I killed isn't dead.
They're letting him live.
I don't think they know there's another team in there.
I don't think they went inside.
They didn't went inside?
Yeah, yeah.
Cause the guy I killed is still alive.
Oh, now they know.
Now they know.
I'm just resting.
I'm gonna run and rest in my bed.
Okay, okay, okay.
At the end of the day...
Cause I have a longbow.
Yeah, I'm just gonna... Goodbye.
Goodbye.
Wait, wait.
Wait, the guy we killed earlier.
They're...
Wait, they're winning!
They're winning!
The team we were fighting is winning.
Oh, no.
Wait, sorry.
Big C.
Yeah.
Yes.
Big C is having some issues here.
They're rezzing.
I'm gonna do something dumb.
So...
Alright, I left.
Are you down two?
You're down two?
I'm down two, but the other team is rezzed.
The other team is rezzed.
The other team is fully rezzed now though.
I fucked up one of them.
I'm begging you to leave the stream for two.
Yo, is that Devontoki?
Alright, they're still in there.
The two I down is still alive.
So I think they're gonna rezz again.
No, there's only one guy.
Alright.
They're all dead.
Well, yeah, but there's still that one team.
What are you shooting me for?
There's that one team.
Oh.
I did it!
Tomato.
I did this.
The tomato luck.
Oh, there's a heat shield.
They use heat shields.
What?
Tomato win!
Oh!
The tomat shots.
We did it again.
Alright, guys.
GG's.
That was my last game.
Okay, okay.
GG's too much.
Hello, Desi!
The tomato force.
We have won again.
How about we... You know what?
You know what, guys?
I feel a little generous today.
Let me... Let me zoom in.
Let me do an actual goodbye.
Let me do a real goodbye then for you guys.
Just for you guys.
Why is you a tomato?
Why am I not?
We are at my humble tomato farm.
Why am I not a tomato?
We are at a farm.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
This isn't it.
This is not the song that we need to play for...
The tomato.
Let me... Let me get some royal...
Hey, guys.
Let me get some royalty free...
Some royalty free...
Country songs real quick for us.
What?
Oh, thank you, Ninja.
Thank you, Ninja for the $15.
Dick.
That's what Scooby do, by the way.
Let me... Alright.
Farming... Farming royalty free.
Here we go.
That... This seems like...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Wait, wait.
There we go.
The pure... There we go.
Weird.
This is it.
Alright, guys.
Thank you for coming to my tomato farm stream.
Thank you.
Oh, time to blow a kiss.
Alright, Espeny.
Before I end it, let's give a kiss to Espeny real quick.
Everyone close your eyes.
This is a tomato kiss for Espeny.
Oh, should I eat some children...
Some tomato children before I go?
Chat.
Do I...
Do I eat...
Alright.
Lucky for you guys.
Oh, sh...
Alright, for Ruby real quick.
Let me hydrate real quick for this.
Just wiped out tomato town.
Alright, guys.
Let me pick some children up real... real quick.
Chat, let me pick up...
Let me pick up some children off the ground real quick.
Alright.
Which kid wants to be consumed?
Huh?
Oh, there you are.
Good choice.
Alright, kids.
You ready to go in... go in tomato papi's mouth?
Mmm.
Every bite I get stronger.
Delicious.
Why am I saying that?
Alright, guys.
Guys, do you not know?
If you too want to join the tomato farm, just do exclamation point discord to join the farm.
And if you are a subscriber...
You too...
If you subscribe, you can become a farmer.
You can be a tomato farmer at my tomato farm.
To harvest my tomato children, so I can get stronger.
I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
I had a lot of fun today.
I did.
I had a lot of... I hope you guys had a great time.
A great April 1st.
And I love you guys.
Thank you guys always for...
Thanks you guys for always coming hanging out with me.
I really like this stream.
I wanted to give you a little tomato dance before going again.
I'll see you at my next stream.
We'll have some tomatoes, too, so we can take off my jokes and take off my three points.
I'll take my new three points off my Yeah.
I'm not on aao.
Ok?
Alright guys, I'll see you guys next time.
Bye!